You know,
they say that we are more divided than ever.
Right?
That's what they say.
Whoever the hell they are.
They keep saying it.
And A,
I don't know that,
that I believe it,
but I thought the best way I can start this,
and it's sort of why I knew the show is to bring people together,
but they keep telling us that,
you know,
we hate each other.
We're more divided.
So I thought maybe you guys should look around the room and just kind of look
and realize how much you hate everybody.
Hello.
I've been really taken a look at another table and just really everyone to
please don't,
I'm not just doing this for what really look at each other.
I mean you see,
yeah,
you hate them and they hate you and the white people and everybody else and it's
all so stupid.
Uh,
all right.
But I thought what I should do actually is take a little poll cause I want to
read the room.
How many of you would say that you're conservative?
It's by a round of applause.
How many conservatives
[inaudible]
conservatives?
Always very respectfully.
You first raise your hand.
We don't make a lot of noise.
Conservative.
We're conserving the applause.
Conservatives.
That's good.
Look.
And that's great.
You know people with jobs and families.
I know you're dressed right.
I saw you.
I could've picked you all out.
It's very easy.
Oh well there's someone who's wearing clothes that fit probably a conservative.
How many,
how many of you are Libertarians?
Liberty
[inaudible].
Very special libertarian.
Libertarians.
Yes.
Anyone that just supported those are the people you can get pot from.
Libertarian love hot.
Just a quick sidebar.
I went to one of these,
you know,
I was getting medicinal marijuana for my [inaudible] black Oma.
But then,
uh,
but now it's legal I guess that you just can show up when your id or whatever.
So I went just a couple of days ago,
uh,
to the pot shop.
And do you think it is impossible to get weed at a hot shot?
Have you been at we got oil,
we got rocks,
we got edibles.
I was like,
do you have a bleed?
And we've formed that even a thing.
I mean,
I wasn't in college not long ago.
Like of Schwag.
That'll be fine.
Schwag,
is that a word?
All right.
Live.
We didn't conservatives,
we did a libertarian.
How many of you,
how many progressive's how many
rested?
I'm guessing there are,
but I know because of the soil and stuff,
I'm
a little different in comedy.
For me,
I'm going
back.
I mean,
I used to do this.
This is what I did.
Okay.
I forgot that I'm good at this.
All right,
so we,
uh,
not one and no one will say it.
I mean,
we're not going to take,
shoot you.
Oh,
we have one.
We have one.
Typically take.
Okay.
It's all right.
You're wrong.
I think it's great.
It's great.
Uh,
that I'll let it be.
Okay.
So we did a conservatives,
we did libertarian,
classical,
liberal
[inaudible]
of course would be my people otherwise known by the,
uh,
the media as much.
You're racist,
bigoted.
Homophobes uh,
no,
just kidding.
Those are good people who believe in the individual,
which is what I believe in.
All the things that I'm,
that I'm constantly talking about.
And how many of course to to cap this off.
How many all bright,
and you can just do it by a show of hands.
That is a great lab.
Do you have right there?